Pedro Castillo el congreso peruano
aprobó levantar la inmunidad
presidencial para juzgarlo por la
justicia ordinaria la medida otorga una
vía de acción directa a la fiscalía en
el proceso en su contra por rebelión y
conspiración con 67 votos a favor el
pleno del Congreso aprobó el proyecto de
resolución del Congreso que levanta la
prerrogativa de antejuicio político al
ciudadano Pedro Castillo por la comisión
flagrante de delitos y declara haber
lugar a la formación de causa penal
entre tanto horas antes la presidenta
Dina boluarte anunció una decisión
paliativa a la crisis y presentó al
legislativo una propuesta para adelantar
las elecciones He decidido asumir la
iniciativa para lograr un acuerdo con el
congreso de la república para adelantar
las elecciones generales para el mes de
abril del 2024 en los próximos días
remitiré al congreso un proyecto de ley
de adelanto de las elecciones generales
para hacer con con las fuerzas políticas
representadas en el parlamento a pesar
del aviso continúan las protestas los
manifestantes exigen el adelanto del
sufragio previsto para 2026 y la
liberación de Pedro Castillo no no
representa es una traidora es una
incapaz y ahorita tiene que estar presa
porque ya hay muchos muertos en el país
y en ese sentido nosotros vamos a
continuar hasta que nuestro presidente
se ha puesto en libertad
boluarte declaró el estado de emergencia
en las zonas donde las muestras de
descontento alcanzaron mayor magnitud
mientras que grupos campesinos e
indígenas iniciarán una vuelta
indefinida desde este martes para unirse
al llamado de comicios anticipados